عاده ما تشتهر سويسرا عالميا بتقديم
الخدمات المصرفيه للاغنياء في شتى ارجاء
العالم فقد اعلنت جمعيه المصرفيين
السويسريين ان البنوك السويسريه تمتلك
اصولا بقيمه سته تريليونات ونصف التريليون
دولار اي ما يعادل ربع الاصول المصرفيه
العالميه الا ان القطاع المصرفي في البلاد
بدا في السنوات الاخيره يعاني من سلسله من
الفضائح والمعارك القانونيه العامه
والخسائر وهو الامر الذي تسبب في انهيار
بنك بشكل اصاب القطاع بصدمه صعبه
الاستيعاب لكن هل تشكل صفقه استحواذ على
منافسه الاصغر بنك نهايه للازمه حتى الان
لم تطفئ عمليه الاستحواذ على هذا البنك
نيران الازمه المصرفيه العالميه تماما اذ
يواصل المودعون الهروب من البنوك الصغيره
التي لا تزال اسهمها تتهاوى اكثر من ذلك
باتت الخشيه من انت العدوى الى البنك
المستحود على كريدسويس فقد خفضت مؤسسه
نظرتها المستقبليه لبنك الى سلبيه متوقعه
ان تسبب صفقه الاستحواذ على
مخاطر تنفيذيه كبيره
زعيم الاشتراكيين الديمقراطيين في مجلس
النواب السويسري حذر من ان حزمه الدعم
ترقى الى مخاطره هائله كما اعتبر ان بنك
يوبيس الجديد قد يمثل ايضا خطرا كبيرا
وذلك باجمالي اصول تقدر بنحو 1700 مليار
دولار وهو اكبر من ان تتحمله دوله مثل
سويسرا وقد رفضت وزيره الماليه السويسريه
كارين كيلر تسميه الصفقه بانها بمثابه
انقاذ بل اعتبرتها صفقه تجاريه بحته اما
محمد العريان كبير المستشارين الاقتصاديين
في مجموعه اليانس فقد وصف هذه الصفقه
بالزواج القسري غير المتكافئ واكد العريان
ان صفقه يو بي اس المتسرعه للاستحواذ على
منافسه لم تكن الحل الافضل لا تبدو
الخيارات الراهنه بمثابه الحل للازمه
المصرفيه في البلاد حيث كانت تلك الصفقه
تتراوح بين التاميم والانهيار وهو ما
تحاشاه السلطات السويسريه لكن هذا لم يمنع
صحفا محليه سويسريه من وصف هذه الازمه
المصرفيه بانها فضيحه تاريخيه للبنوك
السويسريه